[Musique]
en 2016 en pleine crise avec la russie
l'ukraine envoie en chine ce train de
marchandises en contournant le blocus
russe le cren fait enfin partie de la
route de la soie proclame le ministre
crée
la chine a des relations diplomatiques
et commerciales avec l'ukraine son
premier fournisseur de maïs depuis
trente ans et a toujours défendu sa
souveraineté
ce qui n'a pas empêché d'accroître ses
échanges avec la russie avec en 2019
l'ouverture du gazoduc sibérien sous les
regards de jean ping et de la lumière
poutine fasse passer à qui on demande de
donner l'ordre d'ouvrir le gazoduc
après s'être jurés une amitié des liens
sans limite avec vladimir poutine à
l'occasion des jeux olympiques de pékin
le leader chinois marche sur des oeufs
sur la question de l'invasion de
l'ukraine la chine sabcestbien car ce
qui lui importe avant tout ce sont ses
propres intérêts et ses clients des
nouvelles routes de la soie avec l'union
européenne au premier plan
plus de 100 pays ont adhéré à la belle
tango d'initiative br i ou en français
nouvelle route de la soie un projet
lancé en 2013 et cher au président jean
ping et qui évoque les voyages de marco
polo de la chine en europe
le choix nucléaire est un axe
emblématique effectivement des nouvelles
routes de la soie développement du
chemin de fer vers l'extérieur de la
chine qui encore une fois ne date pas de
2013 ça faisait déjà plusieurs années
que les chinois cherchait à connecter le
réseau chinois vers l'extérieur donc
vers la russie frédéric lasserre et co
auteur d'un livre récent sur le sujet
les chinois précisément aussi une
dimension maritime au projet de nouvelle
route de la soie donc entendent
développer et favoriser le développement
portuaire
construire de nouveaux ports prendre des
participations dans des ports à
l'étranger donc plusieurs volets pour
favoriser aussi le développement de ces
nouvelles routes de la soie dans le
domaine maritime en développant des
routes qui existait là encore depuis
longtemps à l'image symbolique de la
ville de chongqing la chine veut
absolument faire croître son économie et
développer les régions du centre et de
l'ouest de la chine comme le xinkiang
avec ses huit jours
donc importer des matières premières et
exporter des produits finis avec de plus
en plus de valeur ajoutée
exporté aussi la technologie chinoise
avec des projets clés en mains vides
fait est souvent bien faits la chine
dames aussi le pian au japon en
construisant des tgv un peu partout dans
le monde il s'agit essentiellement de
fournir des occasions d'affaires pour
les entreprises chinoises effectivement
dans des accords que l'on présente comme
gagnant gagnant avec les pays
partenaires de nouvelle route de la soie
donc ce sont des projets 10 ans soit
promouvoir l'exportation ou la
construction d'infrastructures
offrant des services dans les pays
partenaires mais pour lequel les
contrats seraient octroyés à des
entreprises va donc leur donnant des
débouchés à l'exportation des douches et
supplémentaires mais attention la chine
investit pas elles prêtent facilement
c'est pourquoi un pays lourdement
endettés comme l'argentine est venu se
joindre pendant les jo de pékin au
nouvelle route de la soie pour beaucoup
d'états de la planète qui sont en
délicatesse financière avec les finances
les institutions financières
internationales où les banques
occidentales la chine demeure un recours
qui peut être intéressant d'explorer
pour construire des ports comme celui de
colombo par exemple elles prêtent sans
condition de rectitude politique ni
souci pour la corruption mais attention
la chine ne fait pas de cadeau incapable
de rembourser son prêt le sri lanka est
obligé de céder à la chine son deuxième
plus grand port pendant 99 ans
[Musique]
cette splendide autoroutes au monténégro
ne va nulle part 40 km ont été
construits engloutissant le cinquième de
la dette étrangère du pays mais il en
manque 130 on appelle ça le piège de la
dette
le gouvernement chinois apparemment
aurait donné comme consigne aux banques
chinoises d'être un peu plus sévère un
peu plus critique dans l'octroi de
certains prêts donc on a vu
effectivement une baisse des prêts
accordés par les banques dans le cadre
des projets de nouvelle route de la soie
pour sécuriser ces routes maritimes la
chine contrôle une bonne centaine de
porcs dans des endroits stratégiques
comme panama ou djibouti avec une
première base militaire
en italie et en grèce également ce qui
inquiète les occidentaux qui pourrait
croire qu avant même ses intérêts
économiques la chine recherche
l'hégémonie hégémonique ça me semble un
petit peu exagéré la chine de classe on
prétend pas être la seule superpuissance
même à l'horizon 2050 en tout cas pas
encore elle voudrait simplement être une
super puissance à l'horizon 2050 si
possible devant les états unis
en attendant la chine surveille la
réaction du monde à l'invasion de
l'ukraine tandis que l'occident pense
aux visées de celle ci sur taïwan
qu'elle considère comme territoire
chinois et non pays souverain